yeah so why two degrees with many people
have grappled with that there are some
possibilities are scientifically based
and there are more like it's a political
expediency thing I mean if you talk to
policymakers they will say we needed
some aspirational target which to
scientists aspirational means you're not
going to need to always but but they
actually mean to motivate people to do
things and I wanted to be nice and clean
30 degrees is a good number also there
was some research done by people
including my colleague Jonathan
Gregory's now reading that suggested
that and when Greenland got to two point
seven degrees it would melt and it would
be optimally but slowly seven meters of
sea level rise which would be
catastrophic
and two point seven degrees in Greenland
is of all the two degrees globally it's
a bit assess a bit less than that so
some people think that the two degree
target came from that my suspicion is it
was partly that it was partly a kind of
thing that happened the policy is just a
to and fro about this you know is it
we're gonna I mean something would like
it to be one degree you think well how
and others are saying well it should be
four or five degrees so you end up a
little war in two degrees whereas stuck
there is no real scientific basis for it
being exactly two degrees of course I
mean no one believes that the world's
can render two degrees but the risk goes
up through time so the question is what
degree of climate risk are we prepared
to take and that's the kind of again a
subjective thing but the policymakers at
least have decided to degrees is what
they want to avoid but even at two
degrees and I still presumably gonna
cause significant Greenland ice melt the
Greenland thing it yes it probably will
and if you're in low-level low-lying
islands then they would say what you
talking about dangerous climate change
for the future always happened you know
we're getting flooded so this is such a
subjective thing you go to Russia and
Siberia they would say many would say
we're lucky bit warmer thanks very much
so
this is not any by any means dangerous
even in the UK sometimes people say
global warming bring it on you know so I
don't think I don't think the issue of
two degrees is it's very helpful anymore
even though it's the only thing we've
got because they think about motivation
of targets is their only motivation or
when you believe you can meet them as
soon as you believe you
they become demotivational so it's
possible that in this cop or future cops
or the discussions around the cops they
will start to think about whether they
reframe the whole thing so danger then
the whole policy backs off but you can't
get to the point where the target looks
on achievable by the mechanisms being
used to get there because then people
just go this is silly the earth will
warm by two to four degrees
we just can't nail it down any better
than that this the science is fairly
complicated there are lots of things
that happen to the carbon so it's just a
problem we have to live with that we
don't know whether it's 2 degrees or 4
degrees or off into the fields whether
it's 4 degrees or 8 degrees